joe biden's poll numbers swirl the drain
the u.s surgeon general warns of a
mental health crisis among young
americans and we talk about the true
causes of our civilizational malaise i'm
ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
show
[Music]
the bench bureau show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn.com
ben well there's one substance
throughout human history that has been
known to always hold value that
substance of course is gold there's a
reason why humphrey bogart was searching
for it in treasure of the sierra madre
as opposed to you know u.s government
bonds and this is one of the reasons why
you should be looking to diversify at
least a little bit into precious metals
today every day the left is making
another money grab whether they're
looking at your accounts or taxing your
unrealized gains there's no shortage to
their creativity when it comes to
stealing your wealth to fund their
terrible agenda i've said it before i'll
say it again you're making a mistake if
you've not diversified at least a little
bit into precious metals you can hold
gold in a tax sheltered account or hold
gold in a safe at your very own home i
buy mine from birch gold it's the only
company i trust and recommend when you
buy gold from birch gold by december
23rd they'll send you free gold for
every 10 grand you purchase with
thousands of satisfied customers and an
a plus rating with the better business
bureau you can trust birch gold to
protect your savings text ben to 47 47
47 to claim eligibility for their free
gold with purchase offer by december
23rd you know one thing that has never
been worth zero no not leban brothers
not us government bonds gold text ben
247 47 47 protect your savings today go
check them out right now by texting ben
247 47 47 okay so uh joe biden's
approval ratings are just absolutely in
the toilet there's a new poll out from
ini and tipp
and it shows that joe biden is swirling
the drain
the poll asked who do you want to see
run for president on the democratic
ticket in 2024 joe biden was named by 22
percent of those asked
twelve percent said vice president
kamala harris none of the rest of the
democrats rose above single digits the
much beloved booty judge garnered four
percent aoc elizabeth warren
massachusetts representative joe kennedy
for some reason and stacey abrams each
attracted three percent support
meanwhile six percent of all those who
answered preferred someone other than
those on the list 31
said they were unsure
if the numbers suck only 37 percent of
democrats say they are enthused about
joe biden holding the top spot and only
16 percent say they want kamal harris
and no one even gets more than low
single-digit support after that
the numbers for joe biden continue to
decline there's another poll out today
and shows voters pessimistic about the
economy biden's leadership is according
to a new wall street journal poll
the survey according to the wall street
journal reveals a set of danger signs
for the democratic party as it prepares
to defend narrow majorities in the house
and senate voters by a large margin see
economic and fiscal issues including
inflation as top priorities for
washington and they view the gop as
better able to handle them
joe biden's overall approval rating
right now is at 41
his disapproval is at 57 percent what's
much worse for joe biden he strongly
approve of joe biden number is 19
he's strongly disapproved of joe biden
number is 46
he got 22 percent of the american public
saying they somewhat approve of joe
biden and ten percent saying they
somewhat disapprove but people hate him
much more than they love him for sure
more more voters apparently say they
would back a republican than a democrat
for congress 44 to 41 if the election
were held today that is within the polls
margin of error but again most of these
polls tend to underestimate republican
support and republican turnout
so these numbers are really really bad
for the democrats right now
and as far as whether the country is on
the right track or in the wrong on the
wrong track according to that wall
street journal poll 63
of americans say the country is on the
wrong track only 27 say the country is
on the right track
some 61 percent of americans say the
economy is headed in the wrong direction
some 46 percent of americans expect the
economy to get worse next year compared
with 30 to expect it to get better
margin in favor of the proposition that
inflation is going to get worse rather
than better
people have really bad expectations with
regard to crime by a 33-point margin
people think the crime is going to get
worse not better
26 more americans think that the border
is going to get worse not better
the nation's political divide
50-point margin between people who say
it's gonna get worse and people who say
it's gonna get better
on the issues the gop has an advantage
on the economy inflation and securing
the border
democrats have an advantage on getting
the pandemic under control but again
those numbers are not particularly
stellar on improving education it's
fairly evenly split on making health
care affordable democrats have an
advantage but the issues americans care
most about rebuilding the economy and
getting inflation under control
republicans have massive advantages so
democrats have a real problem on their
hands but the bigger issue here is that
americans just seem consumed with the
idea that the future is going to suck
and and i think one of the reasons that
they feel consumed with the idea of the
future is going to suck
is because we as a country seem to have
lost purpose
the surgeon general of the united states
came out yesterday and he announced that
we have a mental health crisis among
young americans which again if you watch
tick tock for any length of time at all
you know is true
you can view my review videos over at
youtube where i go through some of what
goes on tik tok and it is basically just
a mental asylum in full public view for
the laws
it's a bunch of people who are who are
signifying their real mental disorders
and doing so for people to cheer them
the surgeon general had to put out this
53-page report today talking about how
children are in real trouble
according to the surgeon general he says
recent national surveys of young people
have shown alarming increases in the
prevalence of certain mental health
challenges in 2019 one in three high
school students and half of all female
students reported persistent feelings of
sadness or hopelessness an overall
increase of 40 from 2009
since 2009 okay we're not talking from
30 years ago we're talking about just
over the course of the last 12 years an
increase of 40 percent
according to the government of course
this is shaped by
social media it is shaped by
drug use and chip but that doesn't go to
any of the real underlying issues that
are that are innervating the society
according to the government quote we
know that mental health is shaped by
many factors from our genes and brain
chemistry to our relationships with
family and friends neighborhood
conditions and larger social forces and
policies we also know that too often
young people are bombarded with messages
through the media and popular culture
that erodes their sense of self-worth
telling them they are not good looking
enough popular enough smart enough or
rich enough that comes as progress on
legitimate and distressing issues like
climate change income inequality racial
injustice the opioid epidemic and gun
violence feels too slow
of course the u.s surgeon general is
saying the reason that kids are now
suicidal is because we haven't done
enough on climate change or income
inequality or racial justice
or alternatively there's a giant gaping
hole in the soul of america's young
people
and in some of its older people that is
not going to be filled by your bull crap
excuses for for motivation on a daily
basis
the government is also living technology
platforms they say we're not deployed
responsibly and safely these tools can
pit us against each other reinforce
negative behaviors like bullying and
exclusion and undermine the safe and
supportive environments young people
need and deserve all that was true
before covet 19 dramatically altered
young people's experiences at home at
school and in the community the pandemic
era's unfathomable number of deaths
pervasive sense of fear economic
instability and forced physical
distancing from loved ones friends and
communities have exacerbated the
unprecedented stresses young people
already face
our obligation tax is not just medical
it's moral says vivek murthy the surgeon
general of the united states we're going
to go through more of this this advisory
from the surgeon general on the mental
health of young people because i think
it goes to a far deeper culturally a
cultural and civilizational malaise that
is now set in and really is cancerous
we're gonna get to that in just one
second first
let's say that you and your friend you
know you have a bad marriage and it ends
badly with like you and your friend
killing the guy and you go on the run
and eventually the police catch up with
you and you have a choice you can either
be arrested and you can face trial and
face down your sins or you can drive off
a cliff with your friend well as you are
freeze framed above the grand canyon in
the air before your car plummets to the
end of its parabolic arc well as as
you're sitting there next to gina davis
you think to yourself man probably
should have bought life insurance via
policy genius first head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro answer a few
questions about yourself to get started
in minutes you can work out how much
life insurance coverage you need compare
personalized quotes to find your best
price it could save 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius
their license experts will help you
understand your options and apply for a
policy the policy genius team works for
you not the insurance companies you can
trust them to offer unbiased help and
advocate for you at every step until you
are covered policy genius doesn't add on
extra fees or sell your information to
third parties they have thousands of
five star reviews across trustpilot and
google since 2014 policy genius has
helped over 30 million people shop for
insurance head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro get your free
life insurance quote see how much you
can save that's policygenius.com
shapiro okay so according to the surgeon
general the reason that we're having a
mental health crisis is because we're
not doing all the things that the left
wants you to do via the government and
that of course is really silly so first
they try to claim that mental health
conditions that have gotten much more
grave among america's young people that
that is due to biological factors
nah in order to assume that it's due to
biological factors you would have to
assume that over the last 12 years there
has been a major change in the biology
of human minds which not a lot of
evidence do suggest that
environmental factors yes
according to vivek murthy some mental
health disorders seem to cluster in
families they're often shaped by
multiple genes whether an individual
develops its symptoms can be further
modified by experiences and surrounding
environment
environmental factors can range from
exposure to alcohol or drugs during
pregnancy to birth complications to
discrimination and racism to adverse
childhood experiences such as abuse
neglect exposure to community violence
and living in under-resourced or
racially segregated neighborhoods okay
some of these are well substantiated the
notion that if you suffer from
discrimination that this leads to
massive mental health crises the the
suicide the suicidal ideation stats
don't really back that up in fact it
tends to be middle upper class white
people who have higher levels of
suicidal ideation than for example
impoverished black people so if it's
really about class issues then it that
or race issues that really doesn't
explain it
they say that
adverse childhood experiences can
undermine a child's a sense of safety
stability bonding and well-being
moreover
aces again those are adverse childhood
experiences may lead to the development
of toxic stress which can cause
long-lasting change and of course the
answer to all of this is the government
getting involved in everything so they
put together a graphic adopted from the
w.h.o talking about factors that can
shape the mental health of young people
and here is what your government says
social and economic inequalities
discrimination racism migration media
and technology popular culture and
government policies all can exacerbate
mental health problems
neighborhood safety access to green
spaces like parks healthy food housing
healthcare pollution natural disasters
and climate change this is going to
affect your mental health climate change
is going to affect your mental health
relationship with peers teachers and
mentors faith community school climate
academic pressure community support
relationship with parents basically
everything in life can affect your
mental health but what has changed right
this is the big question what has
changed since 2009 to 2019
according to the surgeon general report
from 2009 to 2019 the proportion of high
school students reporting persistent
feelings of sadness or hopelessness
increased by 40
the share seriously considering
attempting suicide increased by 36
that's a huge number the share creating
a suicide plan increased by 44
between 2015 and 2011 and 2015 youth
psychiatric visits to emergency
departments for depression anxiety and
behavioral challenges increased by 28
between 2007 and 2018 suicide rates
among youth aged 10 to 24 in the united
states increased by 57 percent early
estimates from the national center for
health statistics suggest there were
more than 6 600 deaths by suicide among
the 10 to 24 age group in 2020 alone
scientists propose various hypotheses to
to explain all of this
they say that it might be more people
discussing mental health concerns but
they also are blaming digital media
increasing academic pressure i i'm gonna
have to hear why increasing academic
pressure is causing this considering
that our schools are underperforming and
there's less academic pressure to
perform in modern america than at any
time in recent american history
they talk about income inequality
exacerbating this sort of stuff which is
weird because we didn't have this sort
of spiking depression and suicide rate
during the you know great depression
they talk about racism and gun violence
and climate change as factors again it
all comes back to there's a problem in
society and it must be our favorite
solutions that are the actual solutions
now
if you are going to examine what is
wrong with the utes what exactly is
happening with the youth
you would have to go a little bit deeper
than this
right so they talk about some of the
things that have been exacerbated during
the pandemic
they say that if you've lived in an
urban area or an area with more severe
covenanting outbreaks this is
exacerbated mental health problems if
you are worried about covet 19 if you
experience disruptions and routine which
by the way would suggest that the
lockdowns did much more damage to kids
than actual covenant 19 because the
number again of people under the age of
18 in the united states where healthy
who've died of cover 19 across the
entirety of the pandemic is somewhere
between 10 and 20 according to marty
mccary of johns hopkins university so
when you're talking about why young
people are depressed because of coven it
isn't because they're scared of covet or
if they are scared of covered it's
because the adults are idiots
and the reason is because they've been
locked in their homes and told that they
cannot see other human beings
okay but the the bigger problem here is
that again the the government
suggestions as to why we are seeing
mental health problems across young
people in the united states are always
geared toward what can the government do
to fix it and the problem is that this
is not predominantly a governmental
issue this is predominantly a
philosophical issue that has now boiled
down to how we raise our children or if
we even have children at all
some of the most durable statistics in
in mental well-being show that for
example religious people tend to be less
suicidal they tend to have less suicidal
ideation than people who are less
religious
there there's good evidence to suggest
and that class has very little to do
with it there's good evidence to suggest
that rate has very little to do with it
and certainly climate change has very
little to do with it so in a second i
want to get to why i think that that
young people are are more depressed more
suicidal what our culture has taught
young people why we have prepared them
for a life of misery why we have set up
expectations that simply cannot be
fulfilled and yes that are exacerbated
by the culture that surrounds them from
social media but
why they're not robust enough to
withstand that
i mean you have to remember that young
people their grandparents when they were
18 they were jumping off boats at
normandy headed into the face of certain
death and today young people are
suicidal because of instagram so we're
gonna have to decide why we think that
is happening to this extent
first let's talk about the clothing you
wear so the modern workplace is rapidly
changing so is standard work attire you
don't have to wear stuffy uncomfortable
clothes anymore let me tell you my
favorite clothes cut clothing they've
reimagined work clothes by elevating the
classic tee to something you can wear on
any occasion from a formal business
meeting to a casual night out everybody
loves cuts clothing elite athletes
entrepreneurs recording artists they're
all wearing what gq magazine calls the
only shirt worth wearing it really is
the only shirt worth wearing like
basically that's all i wear i took all
of my other t-shirts aside from our
daily wire let's go brandon t-shirts and
all of those other ones they've been
given away to the salvation army cuts
clothing is the most comfortable it's
also the best looking it fits great
it has excellent materials that really
really soft the peekapolo tribal nt i
mean this stuff is really soft they've
got style it's minimalist design it's
not filled with kind of garbage logos or
anything your schedule is busy the
holidays are busier cuts collections of
polos bomber jackets joggers and more it
makes it easy to decide what to wear
year round that's one less thing to
worry about cuts has your holiday
shopping covered with a ton of new
products and special site exclusive
offers every day in december plus get 15
off sitewide at cutsclothing.com slash
ben that's c-u-t-s clothing dot com
slash ben to get 15 off plus can't miss
daily deals go check them out right now
okay so what exactly is missing for
young people
i think in a nutshell what is missing
for young people is a sense of mission
what are they supposed to do
what are they aiming at what is their
life aimed at and it can't be that your
life is just aimed at quote-unquote
achievement because achievement is
instrumental achievement toward what
what exactly is the achievement meant
for phil if it's just about making money
that ain't gonna do it because you can
make a lot of money you can be very
successful but if you actually have not
fulfilled your role in life that doesn't
mean you're not gonna be miserable as
i've said before again
people who are middle to upper income
tend to have higher suicidal ideation as
teenagers than many people who are
impoverished
so the question becomes
what exactly are you aiming at what is
the achievement geared toward well when
you remove the idea particularly from
successful young men and women
that there is any purpose to their lives
when you tell them that the purpose of
your life is authenticity you are always
going to fall short so we have sold our
kids a bill of goods the bill of goods
that we have sold our kids is that they
are completely autonomous spirits
resting in biologically constraining
bodies
we have told them that authenticity is
the only thing that matters and this is
a radical shift in how we bring up our
children because instead of suggesting
them that their expectations that you
must fulfill that there are roles that
if you successfully fill them will make
you happy in life we have told them that
the only thing that you should be
concerned about is pleasing yourself the
only thing you should be concerned about
is finding your true self and then
having the rest of the world adapt to
you and guess what that's not reality
you're setting up your own kids for
failure and when you set up a fake
reality
in which
everybody online is is bragging about
how they've achieved a level of
happiness through a method that
really makes it impossible to achieve
happiness
and when people inevitably fall short
they aren't happy so the reason i'm
connecting this to government is because
i think that one of the reasons that
americans
have such a cynical view
of the future of the country is because
they have been told for more than a
century at this point that american
government can solve all of their
problems as i have said over and over
and over american government cannot
solve 90 of your problems american
government can solve the problem of
whether your neighbor is going to try to
kill you american government might be
able to solve the problem of how to
mobilize in the face of foreign invasion
american government cannot solve your
problem of happiness
all the american government can do is
protect you from the predations of your
neighbors
that's all government really was
designed to do
but if you've been promised that the
government can solve all your problems
and then the government falls short
you're going to be disappointed with
whoever is the head of the government no
matter who it is and the same thing
holds true when it comes to
bringing up kids if you teach your kids
that the path to enlightenment and
happiness is the search within
you're searching in the wrong place indy
they're digging in the wrong place that
is not where happiness lies now
traditional religious viewpoints as to
how to bring up children suggest that
there are certain things that are
expected of kids
and what is expected of kids is that we
are going to civilize you into a into a
role in a community in a society in
which you are expected to not only
better yourself as a character and
cultivate virtue but to better the
community around you and to become a
full-fledged part of that community
you know whenever there is a baby born
in the jewish community
there are blessings that are given to
the kid
and some of those blessings
are that they should reach bar mitzvah
and they should become uh when you are
bar mitzvah or bat mitzvah and you
become an adult and now that comes with
obligation it's not about the party it
comes with actual obligations right the
idea in most traditional religions is
that as you age more responsibility is
put on you and that responsibility gives
you a sense of fulfillment and meaning
and purpose
and then the idea is that you're going
to get married
right it's it's
impovement you're gonna you're gonna get
married you're gonna have kids and
you're gonna commit good deeds
right this is your role in life and you
are designed to fill these particular
roles i've talked about this a little
bit for the past couple of weeks
because i think that as a society we
have decided that roles themselves are
bad right if authenticity is about
throwing off the shackles of a society
that demands things of you and if the
only thing that can make you happy is
fulfillment of traditional roles
and i'm not talking traditional roles
like women subservient to men or
something i'm talking about traditional
roles like wife or mother for a woman or
father and protector or a man if you
throw away those traditional roles
there is nothing that can supplant that
the search for authenticity is going to
be ongoing because there's no point in
which you quote unquote reach
authenticity it turns out that when you
reach authenticity people may disapprove
of your behavior or your authentic
choices may rejoice not to your benefit
but your detriment you might be making
choices that are inherently damaging to
you
it turns out that sometimes you're not
the best judge of your own interest in
fact a huge percentage of the time
you're not the best judge of what it is
that is going to make you happy in the
absence of any sort of societal guidance
this is particularly true of children
who are completely incapable of making
good decisions and yet we have told kids
from the time they are very very young
quote unquote you can be whatever you
want to be now if what you mean by that
is if you try really hard in any
particular field then you can have the
possibility of success that's true but
if you mean that you can be a girl if
you're a boy or you can act in any way
that you want and have it all none of
that is true
and then when we reinforce that
perception with a social media milieu
that takes that has people taking
selfies and bragging about their own
levels of happiness and having achieved
this
chimera of a vision people are going to
be unhappy
you've also destroyed the sense of roles
that are necessary in order to
promulgate community communities require
roles if you interact with other people
you are playing a role they are playing
a role there's nothing wrong with rules
in just a second we're going to get to
the the issue of roles and why the left
fights so strongly against them and why
it's completely emptying out young
people it really really is it's leaving
them aimless it's leaving them spirits
without flesh and that is not something
that can be rectified quickly or easily
first let's talk about a great gift you
can get for somebody this holiday season
so we have one of our old sponsors is
back better than ever i'm talking of
course about vincero collective so if
you don't know vincero they're a small
team based out of san diego they provide
today's most ambitious people with
premium watches and lifestyle
accessories they've got eye-catching
designs quality craftsmanship you can
feel in hand ventura provides incredible
pieces sure to become staples of your
wardrobe and beyond ventura watches look
at this this is a beautiful vincero
watch okay so i'm a luxury watch guy but
luxury watches are like
tens of thousands of dollars if you are
looking for a great christmas gift that
is not gonna break the bank but looks
classic and looks spectacular vincero
watches are the gift whether you're
shopping for a friend or a loved one
partner or a parent vincero has a
collection and color way for everyone
making it easy to find a great gift for
that special someone don't wait till the
last minute this year head on over to
vincerocollective.com
shapiro check out our favorite picks
while you're there take advantage of 15
off on your purchase exclusively for you
our listeners here at the daily wire we
stand behind ventura collective the
products they sell brand they built
values they stand for you don't need to
take my word for it with over thirty
thousand five star views vincero offers
you a shopping experience you can trust
and you can be at ease with their 5-year
guarantee and 365-day free return policy
support our show do yourself a favor
check out vincero collective we know
you're going to be happy once you do
because the pieces look great go check
them out right now and get 15 off when
you use promo code shapiro it's a
perfect opportunity to get yourself or a
loved one a gift they won't forget go to
v-i-n-c-e-r-o-collective.com
forward slash i've got inventories for
like everyone in my family they're
really great vincero collective dot com
forward slash shapiro okay so
let's get into a little bit of of the
roles that you are meant to play over
the course of your life
so we are embodied being this is the
place to start when we talk about human
nature we have to understand that we're
not free-floating spirits in the machine
we can't just make up our own reality
and biology is not an obstacle biology
is part of who you are
right you are not just a spirit and you
are not just biology you are both and
they are combined
and what that means is that your biology
is not your enemy sometimes it's
something you have to curb
but it is not in fact opposed to you
it's not an obstacle you don't get to be
quote unquote whatever you want to be
regardless of your biology right i'm
five nine i'm an orthodox jew i ain't
playing in the nba
i can't be whatever i want to be
yeah i can be what i'm capable of being
okay but we have decided that that's not
true we have decided because we are so
fixated on this idea that all autonomy
is sort of in your head
that
children ought to be granted autonomy
they are not capable of of having my
children ought to be making decisions
about for example their own gender when
they're five years old which is totally
insane
my son is not even capable of deciding
what to eat in the evenings
he's not capable of deciding whether he
should go to school if he had his way he
would never go to school
but we have told kids that they are to
be treated like little adults which they
are not
instead there are roles that we play
over the course of our life some of
those roles have to do with aging when
you are young you're a learner that
means you need people who are shaping
and guiding you people who are giving
you a sense of mission
as a citizen in your community you have
to believe in the collective purpose of
that community if you're an american you
have a role as an american and that role
is to uphold the founding principles of
the declaration of independence and
constitution of the united states that
is your role that role exists in every
nationality in world history
it is only in the modern era that we
have created
nationless people who believe that they
are citizens of the world there's no
such thing as a citizen of the world
honestly try paying taxes to the world
you're a citizen of whatever country you
reside in
and so either you should become a
full-fledged citizen and act like a
citizen or you should move
and what that means is a certain level
of loyalty to the core philosophy of the
nations which you belong you have a role
as a parent that role is not to abdicate
the responsibility for bringing up your
kids
it's the role of cultivating yourself
virtuously so you can bring up your kids
properly and inculcate in them certain
values
you have a role as a husband or as a
wife
right and that role as a husband or a
wife is to cultivate yourself become a
better more caring human being
and yes to be the other half
of the person of the opposite sex to
whom you're going to commit your life
and then produce children within that
marriage these are historically approved
roles and when people look at the wisdom
of the past and they scoff at it and so
why can't we just remake the world today
the answer is you're being an idiot
because wisdom of the past is there for
a reason it has been tried it is true
now that doesn't mean there can't be
incremental changes it doesn't mean that
certain conflicts of the past don't crop
up and force us to rectify them
and this is not a hegelian notion that
everything that was was meant to be
but it is true that if something has
lasted the test of time thousands and
thousands of years there probably is
something to it beyond what your pee
brain thinks there is
the way that most people are inculcated
in a culture is not even that you are
sat down and taught that marriage is an
inherent good it's that you watch your
parents being married and you realize
that it's an inherent good
it's not that you look around and you
think okay well freedom is a good thing
and i've rationed i've rationalized it
out of my brain
as michael oakshott the philosopher has
suggested most politics is not
rationalism most politics is inculcated
in the water and in the air we breathe i
was once sitting with sam harris of
course is a famous atheist
and we were talking about values and i
was pointing out that he gets his values
from the same place that i do namely a
judeo-christian culture in which he was
raised because he was saying well i came
up with these values you know myself and
and i've thought them through and i'm
sure he has thought them through but the
reality is that sam harris and i share
80 of values 90 of values that's because
we grew up like 10 miles from each other
in california
in a society that was built on several
thousand years of common history
that
being a part of that stream being a
person who fulfills roles ins that is a
fulfilling thing it is a good thing it's
a thing you're supposed to be teaching
your kids because you cultivate virtue
within each of these roles right each of
these roles requires you to follow
certain rules and also to exercise
certain liberties in order to be a good
parent you have to stick and move in
order to be a child who's properly
learning you have to have the freedom to
learn in order to be somebody
who acts as a good american citizen you
have to exercise your freedom to produce
right you have to you have to exercise
your freedom to be creative
and all these things are inherent goods
but they don't exist in the absence of
roles for which they are designed they
are instrumental goods in other words
most of the things we think of in in
life as inherent goods are not inherent
goods they're instrumental goods they're
directed toward a higher good
toward a larger purpose
and when we sort of make the morally
relativistic point that no these are
inherent goods freedom is inherent good
not freedom directed sort of higher
purpose freedom just itself well then
you've created no limits for people and
that's not fulfilling the reason that
people ask people you know if you ever
want to see truly what people's lives
are about go read obituaries and go read
obituaries because i'll tell you what
obituaries never say this person
identified as a person of gender x
this person
interacted with their colleagues on
twitter these are things that don't make
the obits and if you really want the
boiled down version the really boiled
down version go check out gravestones at
the cemetery at the gravestones at the
cemetery usually say things like beloved
father and husband a beloved mother
these are the things that that people
want to be remembered as it's role
fulfillment okay now as a society we've
decided that these roles are not only no
longer necessary they're repressive and
bad and they are and they ought to be
fought and we are teaching our kids this
and then we are shocked that our kids
are depressed we are shocked that our
kids are are looking for authenticity in
all the wrong ways
we are shocked that when they go
searching for what is me and they come
up short they start dosing themselves
into oblivion
when we remove them from a communal
context in which you are naturally
forced to play a role right if you've
ever been in high school you know this
right you play a role in high school but
you play roles throughout your lives and
here's the thing even when we pretend
that there are not roles to play you end
up playing a role
but the role you play might be a toxic
role the role you play might be is the
court jester the role you play might be
as the example to others of how not to
live your life there are a lot of roles
out there pick ones that matter
and the ones that matter typically are
the ones that have to do with
historically tried and true roles that
have provided to fulfillment to people
across cultures for all of human history
but here in the united states in our
pursuit of this
bizarro world
complete autonomy and complete
libertarianism is the is the solution to
all your ills authenticity
is what we ought to be searching for and
we will raise our kids to search for
authenticity
they've lost what makes people
authentically human which is human roles
human roles make you make you human
otherwise just an animal
otherwise you're just a really smart
animal
so the reason that i bring all of this
up of course is because we see
indicators of how we've undermined the
raising of our children all over our
culture there's an article in the
washington post today for example
entitled a white teacher taught white
students about white privilege it cost
him his job
and the idea is that we should be very
much pro our teachers teaching kids
about racial essentialism
teaching kids about the evils of their
country teaching them essentially to be
bad americans
that it is good for teachers to teach
kids if you by the way if you are
teaching your kids about racial
essentialism you're teaching your kids
to be a bad american you're teaching
them to fundamentally reject basic
notion basic notions of western
civilization
about the inherent rights of human
beings
and about the fact that that
human beings ought not be boiled down to
immutable skin color characteristics
but the washington post says that they
they want kids to be freed of the role
of good american citizen
to even say by the way that you should
play the role of good american citizen
is now considered intolerant these sorts
of words are considered coded quoted dog
whistles to say something like good
american citizen
according to the washington post matthew
hahn checked his phone to see if the
wait was finally over
it had been five months since he was
fired for teaching about white privilege
at a high school in rural tennessee two
months since he had fought to regain his
job at an emotional three-day hearing
becoming a symbol of the acrimonious
debate
over the way race racism and history
should be taught in america schools now
nothing no announcements from the school
district about his appeal effort no
messages from his lawyer no text from
friends and former colleagues but
sustained him through a lonely half year
of jobless limbo could he return to
teaching in his hometown apparently no
one knew han 43 white and balding side
marlow his german shepherd started to
whine han grabbed the leash because no
matter what he still had to walk the dog
shrugging on a grey hoodie against the
fall chill he walked out his front door
and down the long sloped driveway of the
house he had grown up in marlow tugging
at every step
a lifelong residence of kingsport
tennessee hahn was well aware his
liberal views made him an outlier in his
overwhelmingly quiet mostly conservative
community but that had never be never
mattered before he had taught in the
sullivan county school system for 16
years without any trouble he had taught
the class that got him fired
contemporary issues for nearly a decade
without a single parent complaint then
at the start of last year he made a
pronouncement during a discussion about
police shootings that would derail his
career white privilege he told his
nearly all-white class is a fact
then he has signed tana hai sukkot's
essay the first white president spurring
parent complaints
in april a student mentioned white
privilege during a class discussion
about derek chovin and han could not
help himself he navigated to youtube and
pulled up white privilege a scathing
profane four-minute poetry performance
by kyla janae lacy
oh am i making you uncomfortable the
black writer demands at one point try a
cramped slave ship
i will probably get fired for showing
this haunt joke before hitting play less
than a month later he was and of course
it's very bad very bad that han lost his
job because after all we have to have
teachers indoctrinating kids into the
idea
that
america is inherently bad all of its
institutions shot through with racism
and bigotry now again
teaching kids these sorts of ideas when
they are 19 20 is a different thing as a
as one view among many in college
even there i think that there's a
serious question as to whether we ought
to be sponsoring anti-citizenship
sentiments like the idea that racial
essentialism is at the root of all of
america's institutions
but certainly when you're teaching kids
high school kids
are you raising kids to have a purpose
as americans when you do this sort of
stuff serious question and we're doing
this with regard to math too
article today in usa today is math
education racist
debate debate rages over changes to how
us teaches the subject
instead of teaching kids to pursue
success we are now teaching kids that if
they fail it must be the system that has
failed because true authenticity is to
be found within not in fulfilling
standards not in attempting to achieve
as part of a broader goal of becoming a
more productive person who is capable of
doing better things for family friends
community and country
according to the according to usa today
there are recommendations to make math
more inclusive schools are collapsing
math tracks to put kids of all abilities
in the same classes adding data science
courses that carry the same prestige as
calculus long seen as a gateway to a
center to a career in stem fields and
elite colleges another heated issue the
extent to which math education should
include real-world problems involving
racial and social inequities fairly or
not that debate has landed the landed in
the murky soup of critical race theory
digressions the changes have pitted
mathematicians and math educators
against each other and sparked criticism
from affluent parents upset by the
elimination of gifted tracts have caused
upheaval in california as parents
professors and teachers spar over
proposed changes to the state's k-12 and
math framework
the the attempts to dumb down math
education are of course about teaching
people that america sucks
because of inequalities of outcome
and about teaching people that they
don't actually need to fulfill standards
in order to feel
in order to feel better about themselves
but they're not going to feel better
about themselves because here's the
thing there's justified self-esteem and
there is unjustified self-esteem and
we've been teaching kids about
unjustified self-esteem for generations
at this point and it turns out
unjustified self-esteem runs directly
into the shoals of reality even if the
entire society decides to engage in
delusions
the same thing holds true when it comes
to basic biology
and you want to depress kids here's a
great message boys can be girls that's a
pretty great message for depressing kids
first of all people who suffer from
gender dysphoria which is a real
diagnosable mental disorder under the
dsm-5 have extraordinarily high suicidal
ideation rates okay so the the broader
teaching of the lie that men can become
women and girls can become boys
obviously is not tied to mental health
concerns
on a broad societal level we're not
talking about the treatment of people
with gender dysphoria we're talking
about indoctrinating kids into confusing
and stupid and anti-biological ideas
that we are now trying to mainstream in
the real world it's a disastrously comic
effect
article from the uk daily mail today
fury as transgender u-pen swimmer 22 who
used to compete as a man smashes two u.s
women's records in weekend competition
and finishes one race 38 seconds ahead
of her nearest rival
leah thomas 22 smashed two u.s swimming
records at an akron ohio contest
thomas won the 1650 freestyle in a
record time of 15 minutes 59 seconds
beating her closest rival anna sophia
kalindazzi by 38 seconds
38 seconds she left rivals floundering
in a 500 freestyle beating them by 14
seconds
thomas previously competed for the
school men's team for three years before
joining the women's team
ncaa rules dictate any trans female
athlete can take part in women's events
if they've completed a year of
testosterone suppression treatment
okay so um either men are unbelievably
good at becoming women like amazing
in other words women can have to be
women all their lives but men within
five minutes of becoming women are
better at women than like nearly every
athletic endeavor or they're still men
and we as a society are lying in order
to preserve the sense of authenticity of
particular people
a question is that sense of authenticity
fulfilling for most people or
is reality more fulfilling is living in
accordance with reality actually a
rather fulfilling thing
you know biblically speaking when god
places
man in the garden of eden and the reason
i'm using the bible here is not really
for the the religious commentary
although obviously i believe in the
religious aspect of this but because the
bible is the most popular book in world
history and has some pretty wise things
to say it has stood the test of time the
basic metaphor of god placing man in the
garden of eden and telling him
to cultivate the ground
is that the ground exists reality exists
you don't get to remake reality in your
own image because you in fact are not
god
you are not a spirit floating above the
waters you're something else entirely
you're an embodied human being and
playing your role in life recognizing
reality in life is fulfilling take away
obligation take away responsibility to
fulfill those roles and people lose
purpose
they just end up in a in a perfect sense
of malaise
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first
let's talk about gifts for the holiday
season i'm gonna give you a great gift
this holiday season like a super useful
one raycon wireless earbuds raycons will
give you amazing audio quality wherever
you go whether you use them to pump up
wind down work or work out they'd be
useful for anyone on your list even
better for you they started half the
price of other premium audio brands with
their latest model you get three new
sound profiles to make sure everything
you're listening to sounds its best with
just the right amount of bass you got
pure mode for blues instrumental yeah
balance mode for podcast listening you
got bass mode for hip-hop so like the
full shapiro spectrum right you can
listen to me play violin on pure mode
you can listen to this podcast on
balance mode and you can listen to me
rap like cardi b on base mode raycons
are available in five stylish colors so
you can pick a perfect one for everyone
on your list with free shipping and
returns giving is easier than ever the
holidays are coming up faster than you
think now is the time to knock out that
gift list and avoid the last minute
shipping scramble especially because
right now my listeners will get a 15 off
site wide with code holiday at by raycon
dot com slash ben again that's by
raycon.com use code holiday today get 15
off your entire raycon order that is
dot com slash ben we're gonna get to
more on the depression and and suicide
spike that we have seen in the united
states first last week joe biden
announced his winter covered plan it
doesn't sound like a lot of winter
wonderland he's extending the federal
mass mandate for public transport
they're also considering requiring
americans to be fully vast even in order
to fly like get on a plane so if you
want to visit your family for the
holidays you might need to drive across
the country or backs in order to fly the
biden administration is working overtime
to force you to do more this is why we
have filed a lawsuit against joe biden's
vax mandate for private employers the
government does not get to make these
decisions for you but we need your help
if you haven't signed our petition
against joe biden's vax mandate i need
you to head on over right now to
dailywire.com do not comply to add your
name we need to send an overwhelming
message to this administration that the
american people will not comply we have
a goal of reaching one million
signatures which would provide a major
boost to our legal challenge we have
over seven hundred thousand signatures
so far we need your help to cross the
finish line so please sign the petition
at dailywire.com
do not comply and then share that
petition with all your friends and
family let's send a message so loud that
brandon cannot ignore us also if you
have not picked up a copy of matt
walsh's book johnny and walrus you
should in fact you're obligated to by
the dick tots of wokeness why well not
only because his book sold out within
the first 24 hours but because it is now
the number one
lgbtq plus i a a
y z
backslash colon exclamation point
question mark star ampersand
bestseller on amazon and yes the book is
sold out don't worry you can reserve
your copy at amazon to get your hands on
the next batch of shipping out soon
johnny the walrus is an exhilarating
tale of a young boy pretending he's a
walrus which is fun and games until
johnny's mom decides based on internet
searches and yoga classes that johnny
probably is actually a walrus and that
she has to uphold his trans walrus
identity if you know matt's brain you'll
laugh your butt off it's a really funny
book so head on over to amazon reserve
your copy of matt's timely masterpiece
johnny the walrus today you are
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so the the
case that i am making which is that we
need to reinstitute social roles not by
law obviously but culturally that we
need to
re-inculcate in our kids a feeling that
they have obligations and
responsibilities and that this is what
makes us human
there's some pretty good scientific
evidence to this so in the 1960s there
was a scientist named john calhoun and
he performed a bunch of mouse
experiments there was one particular
experience experiment that became very
very famous
he set up an experiment that was
designed to essentially create utopia
okay and this this experiment for mice
essentially amounted to we are going to
put a a bunch of mice in a place where
all of their needs are catered to and
they're they're basically like
rich people today all their needs are
catered to
they don't have any obligations
according to iflscience.com
in this study
which was called universe 25. they set
up all these different experiments with
these mice in this study calhoun took
four breeding pairs of mice and placed
them inside a utopia the environment was
designed to eliminate problems that
would lead to mortality in the wild they
could access limitless food via food
hoppers access via tunnels which would
feed up to 25 mice at a time as well as
water bottles just above nesting
material was provided the weather was
kept at like perfect mouse temperature
which is about 68 degrees fahrenheit
apparently the mice were chosen for
their health they were obtained from the
nih breeding colony extreme precautions
were taken to prevent disease there were
no predators available anywhere in there
obviously
so the mice
normally they spent a lot of time
foraging for food for shelter instead
they basically spent all of their time
screwing which is exactly what you'd
expect about every 55 days the
population doubled as the mice filled
the most desirable space within the pen
where access to the food tunnels was of
ease when the population hit 620 that's
slowing that slowed to doubling around
every 145 days because male society
began to hit problems they were
overcrowded it might split off into
groups
and those that could not find a role in
the groups found themselves with no
place to go
the excess could not go anywhere else
because there was nowhere else to go
so they became isolated according to the
paper quote males who failed withdrew
physically and psychologically they
became very inactive aggregated in large
pools near the center of the floor of
the universe from this point on they no
longer initiated interaction with their
established associates nor did their
behavior listed attacked by territorial
males even so they became characterized
by many wounds in much scar tissue as a
result of attacks by other withdrawn
males so basically the the mouse society
striated as soon as all obligation was
gone there were the successful alphas
and then there was everybody else
the withdrawn males would not respond
during attacks they would lie they're
immobile later they would attack others
in the same pattern the female
counterparts of the isolated males
withdrew as well some mice spent their
days printing themselves shunning mating
never engaging in fighting basically the
instagram stars of the mouse world due
to this they had excellent fur coats and
were dubbed somewhat disconcertingly the
beautiful ones
the breakdown of usual mouse behavior
was not limited to the outsiders the
alpha male mice became extremely
aggressive attacking others with no
motivation or gain for themselves they
regularly raped both male and female
mice violent encounters sometimes ended
in mouse on mouse cannibalism
because their every need was being
catered for mothers would abandon their
young or merely just forget about them
entirely leaving them to fend for
themselves the mother mice became
aggressive toward trespassers to their
nest with males that would normally fill
this role banish to other parts of the
utopia the aggression spilled over
mothers would indeed regularly kill
their young infant mortality in some
territories of the utopia reached 90
percent
this was all during the first phase of
the downfall of the utopia
then there's the second phase this
called second death whatever young might
survive the attacks grew up around these
unnatural mouse behaviors they never
learned usual mice behaviors many showed
little or no interest in mating
preferring to eat and preen themselves
alone
does any of this sound disconcertingly
familiar for our civilization like at
all the population peaked at 2200 short
of the actual 3000 mouse capacity of the
universe and then came the decline many
of the mice weren't interested in
breeding they were tired to the upper
decks of the enclosure the others formed
into violent gangs below which would
regularly attack and cannibalize other
groups as well as their own the low
birth rate and high infant mortality
combined with the violence soon the
entire colony was extinct
calhoun called this a behavioral sink
and here's what he concluded quote
for an animal so simple as a mouse the
most complex behaviors involve the
interrelated set of courtship maternal
care territorial defense and
hierarchical intergroup and intra and
intra group social organization when
behaviors related to these functions
fail to mature there is no development
of social organization no reproduction
as in the case of my study reported
above all members of the population will
age and eventually die the species will
die out
and then he tried to apply this lesson
to man he said for an animal so complex
is man there's no logical reason why a
comparable sequence of events should not
also lead to species extinction if
opportunities for role fulfillment fall
far short of demand by those capable of
filling roles and having expectancies to
do so only violence and disruption of
social organization can follow
kill the rolls kill the animal
and we are doing that as a society
civilization-wide we restore the rules
or the civilization is in serious
trouble i think we all know this down
deep alrighty we'll be back here later
today with an additional hour of content
in the meantime go check out our newest
podcast morning wire on today's episode
they discuss more on the us's diplomatic
boycott of the beijing olympics that
episode is available right now on apple
spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts make sure to tune in also as
you know the daily wire has launched a
film and entertainment division we have
our very first original film shut in
it's going to be released in just a few
weeks we're fighting the left providing
an alternative to the woke crap
hollywood puts out to do this we're
building up our publicity and marketing
team so if you really want to work at
daily wire and you are a seasoned
publicist with experience working in
film or tv we want to hear from you
daily wire is now hiring a director of
entertainment publicity that is correct
it's one of the coolest jobs at this
magnificent company gets a spearhead the
publicity for our series and films it's
a huge opportunity for a publicity
professional in the entertainment
industry who has dreamed of joining the
daily wire team to apply for this
position to view an exhaustive list of
current openings with daily wire please
visit dailywire.com
careers i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here daley wire
editor-in-chief
wake up every morning with our new show
morning wire
on today's episode biden and putin meet
amid escalating tensions the u.s imposes
a diplomatic boycott at the beijing
olympics and the supreme court abortion
case prompts fierce debate join us and
get the facts first on the news you need
to know with our show morning wire